wir Menschen verändern ständig unsere
Umwelt doch über eine der größten
Veränderungen wird leider gar nicht so
viel geredet ich weiß nicht wie es euch
geht aber wenn ich nachts durch die
Straßen laufe kommt es mir manchmal
taghell vor Schaufenster Leuchtreklamen
Straßenlaternen oder auch private
Wohnungen alles ist beleuchtet und das
ist leider nichts Gutes das Problem ist
sogar schon so groß dass Astronauten
unser Licht sehr gut aus dem Weltall
sehen können ich spreche von
lichtverschmutz ein oft ignoriertes und
irgendwie auch dummes Problem aber das
Gute ist wir alle können helfen das
Problem zu lösen und dabei auch noch
selber Teil der Wissenschaft werden wir
haben echt viel Licht hier wie genau
genau darum geht es
jetzt wenn wir in einer wolkenfreien
Nacht zum Himmel gucken dann sollten wir
eigentlich tausende funkelnde Sterne
sehen stattdessen ist für viele von uns
dort nur ein trübes orangefarbenes glüen
dieses Phänomen nennt sich
Lichtverschmutzung okay der Sternhimmel
wäre natürlich schöner aber noch gibt es
ja kein Problem oder oft wird das Licht
nachts ja auch gebraucht und manchmal
sieht es auch einfach schön aus aber was
oft unterschätzt wird sind die
Auswirkungen die das nächtliche Licht
auf die Umwelt hat sowohl auf Tiere und
Pflanzen als auch auf uns Menschen ein
Fakt den die meisten nicht kennen
Lichtverschmutzung ist unterandere
mitverantwortlich am Insekten sterben
besonders nachtaktive Insekten werden
von Lichtquellen angezogen
natürliche Lichtquellen wie der Mond
sorgen bei den Tieren für Orientierung
künstliches Licht stört diese
Orientierung aber sie bleiben bei der
Lichtquelle verlieren wertvolle Zeit und
sterben dann oftmals an Erschöpfung oder
sind einfache Beute für andere Tiere
ähnlich sieht es bei Meeresschildkröten
aus das künstliche Licht in der Nähe von
nistgebieten führt zu einer
Desorientierung der schlüpfenden
babyschildkröten die dann auch
anfälliger für Fressfeinde sind oder den
Weg zum mer nicht finden und auch für
Vögel leiden sehr unter der
Lichtverschmutzung ähnlich wie Insekten
werden sie vom Licht angezogen und
können so die Orientierung verlieren
außerdem stört das Licht den
tagnachtrhythmus der Tiere sodass sie
nicht mehr zuur Ruhe kommen können und
auch du und ich sind Tiere der
bioryhthmus von Säugetieren wird
maßgeblich durch Hormone vor allem
Melatonin gesteuert und die wiederum
werden durch Licht beeinflusst zu viel
künstliches Licht hemmt die Produktion
des sogenannten schlafhormons dadurch
wird die innere Uhr des Menschen gestört
hat und es kann zu Schlafstörungen
kommen besonders für junge Menschen die
nicht selbst entscheiden können wann sie
aufwachen ist das ein Problem aber nicht
nur das der 24 Stunden tagnachzyklus hat
einen Einfluss auf unsere
physiologischen Prozesse dazu gehören
unsere Körpertemperatur die
Zellregulation und andere biologische
Aktivitäten eine Störung dieses Zyklus
kann deswegen mit verschiedenen
medizinischen Störungen bei Menschen in
Verbindung gebracht werden darunter
Depressionen
Herzkreislauferkrankungen Übergewicht
und sogar Krebs trotz alledem nimmt die
Lichtverschmutzung immer weiter zu und
das ganze Licht des Nachts die Stadt zum
Tag macht fällt ja nicht einfach vom
Himmel so wie das Sonnenlicht sondern
verbraucht natürlich auch einiges an
Energie und verursacht damit CO2 und
dabei könnte die Lösung so einfach sein
das Licht muss nur intelligenter
eingesetzt werden die meisten von uns
schlafen nachts jaah sowieso das
bedeutet ein Großteil der Beleuchtung
ist unnötig müssen Geschäfte wirklich
nachts um 1:30 Uhr den kompletten L und
das Schaufenster beleuchtet haben müssen
riesige beleuchtete Werbetafeln die
ganze Nacht über bis morgens früh an
sein oder müssen Straßenlaternen in alle
Richtungen Leuchten man könnte mit
weniger unnötigem Licht viel Energie und
damit CO2 einsparen und das ganz ohne
großen Verzicht okay soweit so schlecht
fassen wir das mal kurz zusammen
Lichtverschmutzung ist eigentlich für
alle blöd und oft gar nicht nötig daher
öfter einfach mal das Licht ausschalten
cool
doch ganz so einfach ist die Lösung dann
natürlich auch wieder nicht welche
Lichter sind z.B unnötig und welche
essentiell manche Lichter sind ja auch
für unsere Sicherheit wichtig wo zieht
man da die Grenze gut das Thema
lichtverschmurzung ist dann doch etwas
komplexer und genau deswegen habe ich
mit dr Christopher küberber gesprochen
er ist Wissenschaftler und Experte auf
dem Gebiet der künstlichen Beleuchtung
und Lichtverschmutzung und er forscht
daran sowohl in Bochum als auch in
Potsdam außerdem arbeitet er gerade an
einem besonderen Projekt das vom
Bundesministerium für Bildung und
Forschung gefördert wird und bei dem ihr
sogar mitmachen und helfen könnt wie das
geht da stelle ich euch gleich vor aber
Chris hat mir erstmal etwas Spannendes
erzählt was ich so noch gar nicht wusste
richtige Dunkelheit gibt es gar nicht
Dunkelheit ist eigentlich eine
menschliche Idee es ist nicht ein
physikalische Dinge unser Sichtsystem
reagiert auf den Kontrast nicht auf wie
hell oder dunkel irgendwas ist und das
bedeutet dass mit weniger Licht man
sieht besser das lässt sich gut an einer
optischen Illusion veranschaulichen und
zwar der Schachbrett Täuschung bei
dieser Illusion sollen die Felder A und
B miteinander verglichen werden auf den
ersten Blick sieht Feld B heller aus
aber wenn man die beiden Felder
verbindet dann sieht man dass beide
exakt die gleiche Farbe haben die
menschliche Wahrnehmung ist darauf
ausgerichtet die vergleichsweise hellere
Fläche auch im Schatten noch als weiß zu
identifizieren deswegen bewerten wir die
Helligkeit nicht absolut sondern über
Kontraste dieser Effekt kann dazu führen
dass wir aufgrund von zu viel oder
schlecht konzipiertem Licht unsere
Umgebung dunkler wahrnehmen als sie
tatsächlich ist es wäre möglich die
lichtverschutzung zu verbessern weil wir
brauchen nicht mehr Licht in unser stad
besser zu sehen wir brauchen eine
bessere ausgedachtes Licht genau aber
dafür müssen wir Licht noch besser
verstehen es fehlt noch an Forschung an
Daten und es gibt noch eine Menge Fragen
z.B wo genau künstliche Beleuchtung wie
stark eingesetzt wir und genau das will
das Projekt Nachtlichter von der
nachtlichtbühne jetzt ändern in die
nachtlichte Projekt wir versuchen zu
verstehen die lichte in unsere Städte es
gibt ein satellite die Aufnahme Macht
von die Erde jede Nacht aber diese
satellite fliegt über Deutschland und
andere Orte um 2 Uhr morgens das
bedeutet es gibt uns nicht ein richtige
Blick von die Erde in der Uhrzeit W die
meisten Menschen sind auf die Straßen
konkret bedeutet das es müssen Daten
gesammelt werden darüber welche Art von
dann nachts wo an sind wie viele es von
welcher Art gibt und besonders wie sich
die Beleuchtung über die Nacht hinweg
verändert und genau da kommt ihr ins
Spiel denn das Besondere an diesem
Projekt ist ihr könnt Teil davon sein
und der Wissenschaft helfen indem ihr
Lichter zählt das nennt sich citizen
science und ich persönlich finde das
mega cool ihr braucht lediglich ein
Handy und im besten Fall noch einen
Laptop oder ein Tablet denn bevor ihr
richtig loslegen könnt müsst ihr zuerst
ein ca 20 minütiges Training absol ieren
es geht hier schließlich um echte
Wissenschaft und nur so kann
sichergestellt werden dass jeder den
gleichen Vorgaben folgt und die Open
Source Daten am Ende auch wirklich
verlässlich sind danach kann man die
Nachtlichter App im Browser öffnen und
sich ein öffentliches Profil erstellen
ganz wichtig ihr müsst dafür euren
Browser erlauben auf den Standort
zuzugreifen und auch wichtig zu erwähnen
ist dass wenn ihr zählt ihr mindestens
zweimal auf eurem Straßenabschnitt die
Lichter zählen solltet also zu zwei
verschiedenen Uhrzeiten in derselben
Nacht denn es geht wie gesagt auch um
die Veränderung der Beleuchtungen um
besser zu verstehen wie genau das ganze
funktioniert bin ich zusammen mit Chris
nachts in die Kölner Innenstadt gefahren
habe das Ganze einmal selbst getestet
und euch natürlich mitgenommen chr dann
erklär mir doch mal wie kann ich das
Tutorial machen man musst erstmal zu
nachtlichtbüne.de gehen und dann auf
Nachtlichter klicken auf Nachtlichter
genau und da gibt's dann einen Link zum
Tutorial wir kommen zum Nachtlichter
Tutorial wir klicken um zu beginnen
perfekt kriegen wir
hin ich habe das Tutorial abgeschlossen
herzlichen Glückwunsch jetzt bist du
bereit die App zu nutzen wir haben jetzt
schon abends die Sonne ist untergegangen
dann lade ich mir jetzt mal eine App
herunter würde ich sagen ihr habt schon
314 000 gezählte Lichter ja 5000
Zählungen und 7000 zählabschnitte also
hoffentlich kann Team dr Watson das noch
so ein bisschen erhöhen let's go also
wir stehen am Beginn unseres Abschnit
den wir ausgewählt haben so halben Meter
weiter und wir haben ein beleuchtetes
pizzchönen das lustig ist es heißt sogar
Pizza App es ist aber kein
beleuchtetchild sondern es ist ein
Leuchtschild das ist nämlich
selbstleuchtend ich würde sagen es ist
mittel es ist so eine fernsehgröße sind
zwei einzelne die aber weiß sind und
dann nicht vergessen auf die AH vier ja
oh hät ich falsch
[Musik]
gemacht
ein Z noch mal ein Z sind wir schon bei
A und wir sind hier gerade mal 4 m
gelaufen oder so wir haben echt viel
Licht
hier das geht ja dann doch relativ
schnell wenn man einmal dabei ist und
sich ein bisschen damit auskennt dann
wird man relativ routiniert erst als ich
mit der App durch die Stadt gegangen bin
ist mir so richtig aufgefallen wie
unglaublich viele Lichter es allein in
einer Straße geben kann von großen
Werbetafeln bis hin zu klein
beleuchteten Klingelschildern alles
erzeugt in unserer modernen Welt Licht
und vieles davon ist ziemlich unnötig
und vermeidbar und das ist nicht nur
meine Meinung sondern auch die von
lichtforscher Chris gerade die
Vermeidung von Licht wäre ein win-win
für alle für Menschen Tiere den
Klimaschutz und auch das eigene
Portemonnaie und das gute ist jeder kann
etwas ändern es gibt Millionen für
Entscheidungsträger in Deutschland die
Lichter installieren oder besitzen wie
z.B jede Ladenbesitzer oder jeder die
ein Haus oder ein Wohnung hat jeder von
uns kann entscheiden ob wir die Gardine
runterbringen spät nachts oder nicht und
ein Projekt in Slowenien hat gezeigt
manchmal muss man das Licht gar nicht
ausmachen sondern nur dimmen hat visuell
fast den gleichen Effekt aber einen
riesen impact hier wieder das Thema
Kontraste von dem Chris vorhin sprach
und ihr könnt wie gesagt alle bei dem
Projekt mitmachen je mehr Daten es gibt
desto besser kann die weitere Forschung
auch Lösungen bieten und dabei hat das
ganze noch echt Spaß gemacht diese
Projekt ist nur möglich wenn ganz viele
Leute mitmachen von verschiedene Städte
in Deutschland und deswegen würden wir
sehr gern euch einladen mitzumachen das
hilft uns enorm danke dir und danke an
die nachtlichtbühne das citizen science
Projekt wird im Rahmen des
Wissenschaftsjahres 2023 unser Universum
vom Bundesministerium für Bildung und
Forschung gefördert macht jetzt mit das
ist der erste Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung ihr habt nur noch im
Oktober Zeit und ihr könnt hier wirklich
Teil von was sehr witigem und gutem sein
danke an euch fürs zugucken hoffentlich
danke an euch fürs Mitmachen und wie
immer bleibt neugierig
euerrick